CHRISTIAN OHNEISER: I'm pretty
certain that we're going
to lose the actual
ice shelf itself
and parts of the West
Antarctic Ice Sheet
at some point in the future.
It will turn into water.
But it's where that water
goes and how much of it
turns actually into sea level
that's the big question, right?
Six to seven meters requires a
whole reorganization of how we
live and our civilization
because you--
you write off some of the most
populated parts of the world,
you know?
Downtown London-- well,
I guess that's gone.
NARRATOR: In order to study the
ice shelf's geological history,
they need to find
sediment on the sea floor
beneath it so they
can sample it as part
of the project in future years.
I mean, we can throw
the stream right now
and then thump our way along.
We just want to make sure that--
that this is the right place.
You know, we've just dragged
all this equipment out here.
The immediate goal is just
see the sea floor-- make sure
it's there and that
it's flat and smooth
and that there aren't
big rocks in the way.
What number are we up to?
LAURINE VAN HAASTRECHT: 17!
CHRISTIAN OHNEISER:
For the science world,
this is a big deal.
You know, we're talking
about megabucks for us,
a lot of time-- a lot of
effort from a lot of people.
This has a lot riding on it.
NARRATOR: To determine if
they're in the right spot,
the team will launch a
hydraulically-driven 500-pound
weight called The
Thumper at the ice,
then use the reflected
sound heard by 96
geological microphones
to create a picture
of what they can't see.
Basically, we're slicing
through the ice shelf,
through the ocean, and
into the sea floor.
We turn that slice on its side.
And they we can see
the different layers
inside the ocean.
We actually tap the
snow out of these things.
CHRISTIAN OHNEISER: So we don't
have a short circuit, right?
MAN: Exactly.
CHRISTIAN OHNEISER:
So our goal is
to actually get that
picture of what's
underneath the ice shelf.
And we hope that our
research will impact
those people that
decide, right, climate
change-- this is a problem now.
This carbon dioxide is
going to kill the ice.
It's going to melt it.
And we're going
to be in trouble.
We've been building
equipment for six months.
And we're just really excited
to actually get into it.
LAURINE VAN HAASTRECHT: Ready?
CHRISTIAN OHNEISER: Yup!
[thump]
[impressed laughter]
LAURINE VAN HAASTRECHT:
There it was.
CHRISTIAN OHNEISER:
You can feel that!
MAN: It didn't trigger.
LAURINE VAN HAASTRECHT: Uh-oh.
Is it triggering on the way up?
MAN: It triggered, though.
CHRISTIAN OHNEISER:
Well, [bleep].
That's not good.
LAURINE VAN HAASTRECHT:
That's just the way it drops.
It hit the switch.
And it triggers the system
and basically triggers the
microphones to start listening.
For some reason, it's not doing
it when the weight goes down
but when the weight goes up.
So we're just trying to sort
figure out why it's doing that.
[thud]
MAN: It didn't trigger again.
NARRATOR: If The
Thumper and geophones
are even milliseconds
out of sync,
the results are worthless.
LAURINE VAN HAASTRECHT: I
think I can see the problem.
The sled has got too
many links at the back.
So now it's not
centered properly.
I think we need to pull
back from it slightly.
All of our systems have
come from different areas
around the globe.
So our geophone streamer
came from Germany.
Our computer system
and the geodes,
they came from the States.
So it is a little
bit nerve wracking
to see whether all of those
components do interact
and whether they work in
an Antarctic environment.
[thud]
MAN: OK, it triggered.
So that's good.
LAURINE VAN HAASTRECHT:
So we're ready to move up?
MAN: Yup, move up.
LAURINE VAN
HAASTRECHT: If our team
is unsuccessful for
finding a proper location,
then it is basically the end
of that aspect of the program.
So I think we are a
little bit worried.
[thud]